Hello. This is 6 Minute.
English from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Phil.
And I'm Beth.
Today, we're going to be talking
about an interesting approach
to the problem of invasive species.
When animals or plants are introduced
to new areas, they can be dangerous
for existing wildlife.
Tell me about it!
Every time I plant something
in my garden, squirrels dig it up.
I'm getting really fed up with them.
Have you tried eating them?
Sorry, what?
Eat the squirrels?
That's right.
One of the simplest ways to deal
with invasive species is just to eat them.
In this programme, we'll be hearing
about initiatives in the UK
and Belize that are trying to get
people to improve things
using their stomachs.
OK, but before that
I've got a question for you, Phil.
Lionfish are aggressive predators
which hunt over
50 different varieties of fish.
To help them do this,
their stomachs can expand,
but by how much?
Is it, a)
10 times its original size; b)
30 times or c) 50 times?
Wow, those numbers all seem
incredibly big.
I mean, it can't be more than ten times,
can it?
Well, I will reveal the answer later
in the programme.
Before that, let's get back
to your squirrel problem.
There's a restaurant in London
that offers squirrel kebabs.
They specialise in food made
from invasive species.
So if that's not to your taste,
you could try Japanese knotweed beer.
This invasive plant has caused a lot
of problems in the UK. But just
why is it so damaging? Host of BBC
World Service Programme,
'People Fixing the World',
Myra Anubi explains.
Japanese knotweed is an extremely
invasive plant that arrived in Europe
from Japan over a century ago,
this super weed doesn't just grow fast,
it has root systems that are
so strong and resilient,
that they can withstand molten lava,
choke out surrounding plants
and cause a lot
of damage to buildings.
Myra tells us
that Japanese knotweed is 'resilient'.
If something or someone is resilient,
then it means that it or they
can resist attempts to stop them.
And another word for resist is
'withstand'.
If you can withstand an attack or damage,
then you don't let it affect you.
We heard that Japanese knotweed's
roots can withstand lava from a volcano.
We also heard that
Japanese knotweed can 'choke out'
other plants. By this,
we mean that it takes the space
and the resources such as light
and water that they need to survive.
And knotweed is not
the only invasive species problem
with a tasty solution. In Belize,
since 2008
lionfish have had a massive impact
on coral reefs and native wildlife.
They can eat four times as much
as native species.
BBC World Service Programme
'People Fixing the World'
went to investigate. Here's Marisol
Amaya talking to Celso
Sho from Marine Conservation NGO
'Blue Ventures' about attempts
by the Belizean government
to get people to eat lionfish.
With a big campaign slogan
'Eat the lion', they
got renowned chefs to prepare it
in exotic ways to raise awareness
that eating lionfish was
both tasty
and helping the environment.
We have developed awareness
for the restaurants to purchase it. Then
we had a lot,
of outreach trying to show
fisheries, the general public, how
to remove the spine,
then that allows them to actually eat
the meat from the fish.
We heard the Belizean government
asked renowned chefs to prepare
lionfish dishes, 'renowned' means
to be well known for being very good
at something.
Celso Sho talked
about outreach work. 'Outreach' is
where an organisation brings
their work to people
through events or publicity.
'Fisheries' are
either the businesses that breed and
catch fish to sell
or the places where that happens.
So, in Belize people are being shown
attractive ways to eat lionfish,
and speaking of lionfish and eating,
I think it's time I revealed
the answer to our quiz, Phil.
I asked you by how much
can a lionfish expand
its stomach to eat more.
And I thought it was 10 times,
but you were wrong unfortunately.
A lionfish can actually make its
stomach 30 times bigger -
that might help to explain
why they are such a danger
to native Belizean fish.
OK, now let's recap the vocabulary
that we've looked at today.
If something is resilient,
then it's very hard to damage.
Yes, you could say that
it could withstand a lot of damage
- it can cope with it.
If one plant chokes out another,
then it takes away
the resources needed to live.
If you are renowned for something,
then you're famous for what you do.
Outreach is how organisations bring
their work to people.
Fisheries are the companies that catch
and sell fish or the places where they do it.
That's all we've got time for today.
Maybe you might want to see if there
are any invasive species near you
that you might want to eat.
See you next time! Bye!
If you like 6 Minute English,
Why not try our News Review podcast,
where you can learn English
from the latest news headlines.